we have now heard from Republican
senator from South Carolina Lindsey
Graham who says that special prosecutor
Robert molars investigation into
possible collusion between the Trump
campaign and Russian officials is now a
criminal investigation what does that
mean and does it even make a difference
let's first hear from Senator Lindsey
Graham his general consensus it was a
good decision to pick a special counsel
a lot of confidence in mr. Muller
I think the shock to the body is it's
now considered a criminal investigation
and Congress's ability to conduct
investigations of all things Russia has
been severely limited probably in an
appropriate fashion
so I think a lot of members what the
special counsel to be appointed but
don't understand that is you're pretty
well knocked out of the game oh come on
there have probably been no crimes
committed here with some exceptions if
you missed that reference last week we
did that story about how Trump's lawyers
said that there is absolutely no Russian
income on Donald Trump's tax returns
with some exceptions which is sort of
like saying I've never killed anybody
with some exceptions so a few things
here first is that it always sort of was
a criminal investigation it was always
potentially criminal there's no real
surprise there so I actually don't know
that the literal statement of this from
Lindsey Graham actually changes anything
materially no I just think that because
Republicans are saying it becomes more
significant it's like how John McCain
said this week that this scandal
compares to Watergate and the size and
scale sure once you have these quotes it
appeals to people and it makes it appear
as though there's a lot more going on
but this is relevant in a sense which is
now that the investigation that's going
to be led by former FBI director robert
muller a special prosecutor now that
it's going to be looking at crimes
specifically number one that doesn't
necessarily mean that one was committed
but there's another relevant factor and
we found out just an hour ago
how relevant this is now that this is a
criminal investigation in the more
formal sense with the investigate with
the appointment of the special
prosecutor it obvious
we involved Michael Flynn and it
protects Michael Flynn in a sense from
being subpoenaed by other investigations
potentially since he is after all part
of a criminal investigation by the FBI
special prosecutor and we learned just
an hour ago that indeed Michael Flynn is
going to be pleading the fifth when it
comes to the subpoena to testify in the
Senate Intelligence investigation we're
going to deal with that more tomorrow so
a big picture this doesn't really change
anything because Lindsey Graham said it
but the other bit of news which might
actually sort of come to a head in the
next couple of days is that a White
House adviser close to Donald Trump
considered a person is now considered a
person of interest in the Russia probe
and it is believed to be Donald Trump's
son-in-law Ivanka Trump's husband Jared
Kushner the initial news according to
people familiar with the matter was
reported in the Washington Post and it
was hey someone who is close to the
president is now a person of interest in
this investigation within hours or maybe
within a day the consensus was that it's
Jared Kushner Kushner was documented as
having met with the Russians
he was documented as having not
disclosed many meetings with Russians
not disclosing meetings with the head of
a Russian bank that is under US
sanctions a person of interest that
doesn't mean you're a suspect often it's
a precursor people or persons of
interest before becoming suspects this
is another sort of step closer to the
current White House in terms of where
the investigation is and potentially
huge yeah that would be a big blow to
the Trump White House because of course
Jared Kushner follows Trump wherever he
goes he's in charge of these big tasks
like solving peace in the Middle East
and taking care of Veterans Affairs and
government reform we will follow it and
we will see if we ultimately get some
kind of formal determination that indeed
it is Jared Kushner at this point so
many things up in the air we will have
to wait and see at least on some of
these issues